[Music]
a woman was in the back of the church
crying out to him and calling him Jesus
this is like the best day of my life
this is just bizarre I meet people that
tell me that when they pray to Jesus
they see my eyes celebrities are
converting to Christianity it's not
about football it's just uh giving glory
to God God is real God loves you your
name folks are becoming Christian well I
think the most important thing you can
do in this life is build your life on
Christ why is everyone turning to
Christianity Russ Jo I wear this as a
representation so you'll never forget
one of the greatest prophets That Ever
Walked to Earth concerning religion in
public
schools so let's bring religion back
let's bring God back into our lives so
as we're beginning to see things become
more Christian are you guys excited
about
this
um in a way more explanation because if
I say no you're like what if you say yes
you're like what so I mean there are
some things that are happening in the
news right now that are very positive I
think here is a interview that was
released with Trump and it was obviously
you can see February 6 right here Trump
has put together a um executive order to
eradicate anti- anti-christian biases
today I'm signing an executive order to
make our attorney general who's a great
person a she's going to be a great
attorney general Pam Bondi
the head of a task force brand new to
eradicate anti-christian bias about time
right
anti-christian bias in addition the task
force will work to fully prosecute
anti-christian violence and vandalism in
our society and to move Heaven and Earth
to defend the rights of Christians and
religious Believers
Nationwide sounds like a good thing I
guess I have a few thoughts on that okay
give me your thoughts because I think
that that that is a good thing nobody
should be being made fun of MH no you're
right but these kind of things tend to
marginalize
minorities like what
minorities well I mean not everybody in
this not everybody in this country is
Christian right so what does it mean to
Stamp Out anti-christian bias does that
mean to the to the exclusion or
government persecution of other group
well you don't agree with us so you know
what Muslims you getes now or what have
you I mean I don't I don't know but but
I guess my my theory to this is is kind
of interesting given his given his
methodology right given his
emo prior
to being almost assassinated
twice on national TV he refused to quote
a Bible verse I'm wondering what one or
two of your most favorite Bible uh
verses are why I wouldn't want to get
into it because to me that's very
personal you know when I talk about the
Bible it's very personal so I don't want
to get into vers I don't want to get
into there's no verse that means a lot
to you that you think about or sight the
the Bible means a lot to me but I don't
want to get into specifics which is a
very simple thing to do and one wonders
could he quote a verse from the Bible
you know and he's like selling Bibles
and all this kind of stuff after being
shot at you know he claims that he's a
changed person and maybe that's true
maybe he is but it seems very consistent
with other things that he's done and
that
is if he believes that God spared his
life and you're not on board with
God you see where this is going like God
put me here therefore any and and you
know that's the Christian God so
anything that's not with the Christian
God that doesn't agree with that well
that needs to go mhm cuz that put me
here it sounds a little bit like the
story of Nebuchadnezzar of like you know
I'm a Christian now and therefore um if
you say anything against Daniel's God
you know okay so I think this is a good
thing that there is protection happening
against a you know an abuse so to say
right I don't want to see Christians
marginalized Christianity has had an
abuse for a long time but let me put it
this way what do you define as
abuse in in fact what do you what you
actually defined as what what what
should get in trouble or not if if if I
have some kind of difference of opinion
of what that church should be about and
I step up and I now say something about
hey the Bible says this but but the
church is doing this and I think that's
wrong am I being abusive well and then
even in Christianity that there's not
cons there's well there's consensus
about what's Christian and what's not
based on Orthodoxy right and if you're
not in that
Circle there's question about whether or
not you're really Christian or are you a
cult yeah so it's a good point I I think
that I think everybody deserves to be
protected in their religion whether you
are Christian or a Muslim or a Jew
whatever it is that that there's laws
for that there's a freedom to believe
what you want to provided that that is
not crossing the boundary where it's
doing harm to other people like if
you're belief is we should be doing
human sacrifices yeah no I'm sorry you
don't get that Liberty you're crossed a
line right but you know I I think that
there's I mean there's also a law that
says you have the freedom of speech and
so as much as it might not be the most
Pleasant thing to receive emails with
hate mail or comments people have the
right to do so which is why we don't
ever delete comments unless they are
absolutely vulgar or unless they
personally attack Our Guest on their
appearance or something like that there
was once when somebody made a bad
comment about someone's physical
appearance it was a guest in our show
and I was like no that's not okay and I
have the right to then remove your
comment but other than that we never
remove comments because you can see when
people hate on us and and that's okay
that's their decision because God is
also a god of Freedom like he Freedom
within means right he has his
Commandments but he does say look you
don't have to choose me you can dislike
me that's your decision right he doesn't
Force anybody to love him and I think
this is kind of Falls in that same
category the Bible also says every word
will be called into judgment and will be
accounted accountable for everything
that you say so be careful what you say
all right moving on there is a
initiative that has been um kind of
popping up in the news again and again
and again of them wanting to put the Ten
Commandments back into the schools if
you heard this
all right so this happened February 10
listen to this state lawmakers this
session will consider two pieces of
legislation concerning religion in
public schools one would provide for
prayer in school for students who opt in
another bill would display the Ten
Commandments Fox for Steven dial in our
Newsroom with details stepen the Senate
bill was filed today and it would
mandate the display of the Ten
Commandments in public classrooms there
are also companion bills to provide a
period for students to pray in schools
if they pass they are certain to face
legal
challenges the topics of Prayer in
school and displaying The Ten
Commandments are once again before
lawmakers in Austin this is the second
time state senator Phil King has pursued
the Ten Commandments mandate it passed
the senate in the last session but
failed in the house state senator Mae
Middleton filed
sb11 allowing students with parental
control to opt into a period of Prayer
and reading the Bible we spend so much
time doing other things a short period
of time for for prayer or for reading
the Bible is not a bad thing good thing
bad thing well there's a there's a
difference uh with before you're
eradicating things that were
anti-christian things against
Christianity and now that that would
basically promote a leveled ground
anyone can you know has the freedom to
do what they want to do without having
anyone against them but now here you're
kind of like almost like push it a bit a
step further than just you know saying
do whatever you want cuz here you you're
putting only the Ten Commandments there
you're making them pray you're making
them read the Bible that's a bi that's a
Christian bias I think it's an
interesting thing when you have seen a
hat that says make America pray again
that's interesting or like the the
picture of Jesus with the Maga hat I
want those principles in our schools I
do um I want them in our homes
unfortunately you know it doesn't happen
in a lot of places but I think the more
important thing is the parents taking
the responsibility to educate their
Christ their children at home with those
principles so that the Commandments are
here not on the walls in the schools I
mean that it's great maybe the kid
doesn't have any other exposure that's
right but Jesus said they'll be written
on the heart right that's Hebrews right
the more important yeah exactly and and
and I hope and pray that that does
something good the point of me showing
you this is like we are at a time that
we know that religion is coming full
swing back into the system yes okay so
we're here we're at this point that now
Christianity is now being prominently
promoted out in the front circles we're
saying we're going to build some
legislation against anybody that says
anything negative about this and we're
going to put all this back into place
and you see these lines between church
and state beginning to cross really
blurry yeah we have a video coming out
that's really really fascinating it's
about about Washington DC and how so
many of the buildings and elements in
Washington DC are direct replica of the
Vatican and how it is quite literally
creating an image to the Vatican that's
right and this is pretty fascinating
when I see things like this what about
the Super Bowl did you guys know and see
that commercial that was played during
the Super Bowl which was a religious
commercial I think this came up in in
our YouTube feed this picture so I'm
guessing it's I didn't click on it but
yeah I I don't remember any Rel saw was
this the only one that they aired uh the
only one yes and it filled two spots
does anybody know how much a a um
commercial for 30 seconds costs on
million okay so how this between 7 and 8
million so this really cost $16
million it was a minute so every time
they play the commercial they have to
pay that amount no well they no no no no
they just played it once dur okay on
yeah okay so I'm going to play the
commercial cuz I want you guys to see
this um here's what the commercial
was your
own
personal
[Music]
Jesus someone to hear your prayers
someone who's there
[Music]
feeling unknown and you're all alone
flesh and Bone by the
telephone lift up the receiver I'll make
you a
[Music]
beli Reach Out And Touch Fai
Reach Out and Touch
Faith wait a minute wait a minute isn't
this song sung or even written by
Marilyn Manson no was it Marilyn Manson
but you're on the right track that is
Johnny Cash Johnny Cash and who wrote
that yeah joh who who was he Johnny Cash
singing come on who was he sing this is
your era and my era yeah I'm young
where did that song come from I don't I
was never a Johnny Cash this isn't
Johnny Cash he's singing a song that was
from the
90s really yes depesh mode Marilyn
Manson has a version of it okay so I'm
Marilyn Manson might have do that this
is a song that came from toes mode this
is depesh mode there's the it's called
the Personal Jesus it was 1990 okay so
this is depes mode right here this is
the words that you just heard your own
personal Jesus someone to hear your
prayers someone who cares someone
Personal Jesus someone to hear your
prayers and someone who's there okay so
this is the song that's playing in the
background
mhm this is the music video to Personal
Jesus a bunch of Cowboys that show up in
the middle of nowhere and end up going
to a brothel and they find these women
that they're going to take in the rooms
and
sodomize that's their personal Jesus wow
so let me ask you a question do you have
a problem with them playing this in the
background a song that literally has
nothing to do about Jesus whatsoever and
you're going to play that as the song to
try and reach people about Jesus it's
definitely in poor
taste well again why would Marilyn
Manson have sung this song clearly he
knew what the real meaning of it was
because here's the back of the CD cover
where he's standing on a wall and
there's a naked girl and when you look
up the video or the pictures for every
single one of this particular single
it's the entire band sitting there with
a girl that is standing in front of him
buck Stark
naked that's wow dude that's not about
Jesus no not at all it's not about Jesus
at all and so this is what some of the
people are are are saying about this
particular commercial Ali Beth St she um
is a
Christian podcaster she's got some
really cool stuff actually I've I've
enjoyed lots of things that she has said
over the years um she says I am for any
campaign that brings people to the
gospel but again he gets us missed the
mark there's nothing in at all their ads
about who Christ is and why we actually
need him it's not even remotely implied
if anything an unbeliever is going to
walk away with the feeling affirmed that
Jesus is at most his buddy who exists
just to cheer him on good point yeah
good well stated there's not much that's
said in fact you know what's interesting
to me how many of you recognized when
you saw this this commercial what were
they doing in the
background um well there were multiple
images so so you got people drinking you
got people LGBT you got people whatever
like that it's it's like he he gets he
gets all of us right yeah I think the
subtle deception here is
that unless we
come to the Bible and and and ask Christ
to show us who we really are then we're
seeking our own personal Jesus and our
own personal Jesus is thinks like us
Talks Like Us makes decisions like us
and never does anything that we wouldn't
do
and the problem with that is we're all
broken sinful human beings yep and so
then I come to the Bible and if Jesus is
just like me I don't need to change MH
and the gospel doesn't do anything
you're hitting the nail in the head
right here the power of the Gospel is to
change us what is it if we're sitting
here promoting Jesus to everybody and
it's like you can live however you want
do whatever you want you can be this
lifestyle that lifestyle do whatever
this has nothing to do with change
whatsoever all you got to do is just
check The Tick box mhm yeah the Bible
says even Satan believes that Jesus is
real yeah and it's it's so subtle
because it's combined with this message
of Jesus loves you and he does he does
he does love you he loves you so much he
died for all your sins but there's a
reason not like Jesus there's a reason
why the Bible says a form of godliness
and denying the power right because a
form of godliness is I'm a Christian I'm
going to call myself a Christian but
there's no change in my lifestyle
whatsoever well that's no power that's
why it says in in the Bible that there's
at the end there going to be two groups
there's going to be people who who did
call in the name of Jesus who did say
hey Lord did I preach and prophesy and
do all these things in your name and
Jesus is like I don't know you yeah so
the Bible th say call in the name of
Jesus and you will be saved because
that's what the thief on the cross did
but there's a difference between yeah
I'll I'll take Jesus or like Lord
I want you I need you what what like
what do I need to do to be saved yeah
and and you know remember the um the
Rich Young Ruler he's like what do I
need to do to be saved and Jesus like
well keep all the commands he's like I'm
doing all these things Jesus said but
you're not you're taking the checking
the Box you're not living it in the
heart there's the Ten Commandments that
need to be kept because Jesus says if
you love me keep my Commandments and God
is love so if you want to relationship
with him you do what makes him happy and
love him but that's the the the idea of
of loving Jesus and accepting him is so
much broader than just checking the box
if you love God with all your heart with
all your mind with all your soul and
Jesus tells you to go do something and
you go I really like my money I'm not
going to go do that I really like this
or that so so Jesus is asking you to do
something which Jesus asked him to do
something and he said no in in both of
those things that you just mentioned the
guy who was the Rich Young
he was missing one thing out of a whole
list of Commandments in the group in
Matthew 7 that you were talking about
and Jesus's rebuke to them is depart Me
me from me you who practice lawlessness
M right that was essentially his same
problem it was lawlessness because it
wasn't the complete fullness he couldn't
get there on his own but it was still he
care about his Brethren he cared more
about himself than he cared Brethren
which was which was exemplified and not
not everybody just because you're rich
you need to go give all your money away
it was he Jesus wanted to show him what
was really in his heart you care more
about your money than you do care about
helping your neighbor in Matthew 7 when
it's when it's kind of flushing all that
out it's like we have to come to terms
with the fact that Jesus has asked
Obedience of
us that's what he died for is our
inability to keep his holy
law but he still asks that it's it's so
holy and so necessary he died for it
because he couldn't change it yep so
it's still it's still up there and and
he's saying look I can help you do it I
can lift you up we can do this we he can
do I'm going to I'm going to pull all
the
way I can account my victory for you
righteousness by faith I have the faith
that God you can do that he can put it
on us to do it which is amazing if you
think about it it's it's so much harder
because God is saying no instead of just
wiping that away he's like no I'm going
to keep it up here and I'm going to pull
you
up by My Own Strength my my power his
you know Jesus I'm going to pull you up
to that level where you need to be so
that you can be everything I created you
to be yeah God God wouldn't say be
therefore perfect even as my Father in
Heaven is perfect if it wasn't possible
it is possible through Jesus
and also to add to what you're saying
about the the law and the Commandments
not you know that he had to die because
we transgressed his Commandments it says
sin is the transgression of the law so
if we are living in sin what does sin
mean it's God transgression of God's ten
commandments so that shows that they
were upheld the whole time they're still
up here because otherwise we wouldn't be
sinting and it makes God a hypocrite if
he's like you know Israel you guys need
to do all these things I've set these
Ten Commandments you need to you need to
obey Jesus comes dies and and then he's
like you know what really wasn't that
important I know people died but you
know we just make that go away hold that
thought that's going to come back up
this is a senator and this is what she
said about these um commercials right
here something tells me that Jesus would
not spend millions of dollars on Super
Bowl ads to make fascism look benign wow
o ouch right all right Hebrews 9:14 um
Felipe go ahead and read this how much
more will the blood of Christ who
through the eternal spirit offered
himself without blemish to God purify
our conscience from dead Works to serve
the Living God I threw this verse in
here because dead works are doing
something that really in the grand
scheme of thing aren't going to do
anything good for you right like it's
possible to do things that you think you
brought up Matthew 7 right that you
think you're doing all these things for
God and it's like he's like I don't know
you go depart from me right so we need
the blood of Christ which what is in the
blood the power is in the blood what's
the power the power to change you cannot
put a version of Jesus out into the
world and say doesn't matter you don't
have to change M okay we talked about
this with Kendrick Lamar we talked about
Kendrick Lamar coming out and saying hey
look I I don't really really care for
the humility that Jesus came from Heaven
down to earth and he didn't put a crown
of thorns on his head it was put on his
head yeah and it's like to make a
fashionable 8,000 Diamond studded crown
of thorns and use it as a fashion
statement but if you have a hundred
people working for 10 months with 8,000
diamonds and who knows how many millions
I have a problem with that mhm not to
mention I have a problem I'm all about
saving gangsters I think this is a great
idea God wants to save everybody but why
are you putting a half naked girl in
your music video right next to those
words yeah don't put filth out there and
blend these two things and his lyrics
are are are somewhat awful he has one in
in his song not like us he says I'm
going to beat your and I'm not going to
say the word and I'm going to hide the
Bible if God's watching wow why would
you say I'm going to beat you up and
hide the Bible because God's watching
like why would you say that if you're
really trying to promote God one of his
other songs is is titled God God's a
gangster M God's a gangster why would
you put the imagery of this out there
and then make a mockery of the last
supper with a bunch of parting and R rry
why would you do that yeah it's a
reverse instead of us being transformed
in image His Image we're trying to
transform his into ours I'll tell you
why this is problematic okay if you guys
want to see Kendrick Lamar and what
we've said about it please go check this
out um later on but you know when he's
literally wearing a crown of thorns and
saying things like this no matter what
you're going through imperfection is
beautiful I wear this Crown they judge
Christ
they judge you they judge Christ he's
saying it's a
representation mhm but I don't think
that's a representation when you're
coming out on stage at the end of your
concert and you're writing your savior I
am not with a light shining down from
heaven putting basically this imagery of
God and Jesus out there and then saying
huge words I'm not your savior mhm
that's imagery burned into people's
minds that's selling them a version of
Jesus with no change MH you don't have
to change you can be a gangster you can
still do what you want you can hide the
Bible what does the Bible say um I'll
hide my hide your word word in my heart
heart so that I might not
s interesting not behind my back
actually said something opposite so I
can hide my Bible so I can beat you yeah
so I can sin I have a problem with that
um so you guys can check this out we we
we talked about this we talked about all
the blasphemy in that other video of of
of some of these other people Kanye West
he's been extremely Blasphemous we
talked a little bit about that Kanye
West was being interviewed and what's a
sad realization is after Kanye West has
has come out and been like Jesus's King
and and he's number one he's now
backtracking and he's like you know what
I don't really care for Jesus yeah he
claims to be God he claims to be God
this is what happens when your
relationship is not
grounded and you not change letting God
change your heart you can profess with
your mouth I believe in Jesus all you
want but that's literally an empty form
of godliness and it's going to not have
the power to do anything and given
enough time you're going to walk away
from God you wonder like cuz he there's
that parable about the different seeds
you know and you you look at somebody
like Kanye and you're like yeah I think
there was a seed he started to come out
and be like you know tell his wife you
need to be dressing this way not that
way and cause Division and but the next
thing you know he's got another wife and
where did all that go she's far more
unclothed than Kim was isn't that crazy
he told Kim you you dressing like this
is is impacting my my but people believe
and see about my belief and everything
else like that and then do that and now
he's probably it looks like he's about
on the verge of divorce so about a year
ago this is what he said about Jesus are
you in that space where you're
comfortable enough to say this is where
I am right now I'm still a man of God
Jesus still is King but this is vultures
right now this is where I am it is but I
you know I I have my issues with Jesus
there's a lot of stuff I went through
that I prayed and I ain't Jesus show
up
wow this is also where he says I'm God
right yeah and I think there's people
that could identify with that you know
they feel like God didn't show up so
let's talk about that for a second so if
I pray to God and I say you know what
God I need this to happen and this to
happen I need billions of dollars and I
need a house and I need like this and
that and you don't answer my prayer God
and am I just going to throw it away
yeah but I think it does go deeper for
people though there's a lot of people
who pray for very serious things like
heal my friend heal my spouse and it
doesn't happen hard to know what he
prayed too yeah I don't think we can
just say he prayed for money or whatever
sure okay but I'm just saying that if
you pray for something and you're like
look God if you don't answer it my way
in what I want I'm I'm going to just
reject you I'll give you an example of
this when I used to go on acting um
auditions and stuff when I lived in
Hollywood I would actually pray help me
to to book this movie or whatever like
plan this part I I mean I made deals
with with God I'll give you all the
money and stuff like this right and God
never answered me not once not once did
I ever book that part that would have
moved me to the next level but did God
answer my prayer he did absolutely
because if I would have gotten those
parts perhaps I would not be sitting
here right now maybe not with the
perspective that that that that I have
right now maybe the money or something
maybe I would be you know off in a e
True Hollywood Story or a ditch
somewhere so I can actually honestly say
God answered it even though it was
different than what I wanted yeah God's
not a Genie or a magic wand he's not for
us to command yeah people assume that
just because God didn't say yes it means
he didn't answer at all and if God is
King whatever the king wants exactly I
mean Jesus himself had that prayer in
the garden of godson mhm right he did
pray Lord you know father if it's
possible pass this cup from me you
know but he it didn't go the way he was
asking right because he even mentioned
in the same prayer you know be your will
be done not mine mhm yeah it doesn't
mean that every prayer even Jesus prayed
for something specific and it didn't go
that way yeah I think that there's
definitely an element of trust in that I
mean I've prayed those prayers I have I
like God I want it to be done this way
or I I'll walk away like I when I went
through a season in my life when I
really wanted to ditch God I I said that
but I can see now it's because one I
didn't have a correct understanding of
who God was the wrong image of God and
two I didn't have enough trust in God
and God was very patient with me we
actually have a whole podcast episode um
we have a different podcast called
little life Studios podcast it's Audio
Only and we actually have an episode
about what to do uh when God doesn't
meet your expectations it's really
interesting um and it was I think it was
actually the most listened to episode of
season one so highly recommend that you
have to learn to trust God even if he
says no even if he doesn't appear to
answer sometimes is not appearing to
answer is an answer yeah you have to be
okay with that and I think when you say
Jesus is King in my life then that's the
perspective you're going to have no
matter how that plays out you're King
whatever you want I ask and hey if you
you you obviously heard so if you didn't
play it out like like I like I was
thinking then maybe I asked wrong you
can understand it from the parent child
relationship because your kids can ask
for all kinds of stuff yeah give me a KN
and you don't say yes to everything that
they want can I your car you know why
you know it's not good for them so so
it's even gone even further than that
listen to what he says about
Christianity Christians we depend on
Jesus so much that we won't put the word
in oursel and the main thing that really
that I don't rock with it's like it's
just always like I'mma pray for you and
it's just like you can actually
physically do something yourself too
more than just pray and we're so in this
mentality that's that's all that needs
to happen but we ain't we ain't praying
our way out of prison we ain't praying
our way out of the abortion clinics we
ain't praying our way to get our land
back that was always ours after
gingification after the Harlem uh
Renaissance and Black Wall Street was
burned to the ground them prayers ain't
working we going we have to apply actual
physical building partnership
what do you notice out of
this I think it's a lot of relying on
self and fixing the problem yourself and
not waiting on God and God you didn't
give me what I want mhm God you didn't
open the door for me so guess what I'm
going to do it myself and is that
trusting in
God no it's not trusting in God at all
and it's eroded and turned his faith
away from God that's very sad because he
has that perspective and and right now
there is a lot of the world that is
getting sold a version of Jesus Matthew
7:18 through1 19 says a good tree cannot
bear bad fruit nor a bad tree bear good
fruit every tree that does not bear good
fruit is cut down and thrown into the
fire you can see what kind of fruit
somebody has if they really have a
belief in God and when you see you know
the Kanye I think is a is a study or a
lesson into what happens to a person
that calls himself Christian but doesn't
actively do the faith work and the
belief work and the trust work that that
is really associated with Christianity
and then letting God change you don't
party don't play in those places don't
do those kind of things you know what I
mean if you do you're going to step on
the Devil's Ground And The Devil's
pretty smart he can walk circles around
us humanity and if you're take putting
yourself outside the the the the
protection of God you run the risk of
creating bad fruit once again we played
the clip of Katie Perry where she
basically says a prayer let's do a quick
prayer then walks out on the stage and
does something that totally is against
biblical
[Music]
principle Thessalonians 29 we know that
Satan is preparing for his final
Masterpiece of deception and this tells
us that whatever is
coming the Bible describes it as a
lawless one so people that don't follow
the law or have a form of Christianity
but really don't care about it deny the
power of it are going to fall prey and
this is what the Bible says Den can you
read that the coming of the the Lawless
one is according to the working of Satan
with all power signs and lying wonders
and with all unrighteous deception among
those who perish because they did not
receive the love of the truth that they
might be saved and for this reason God
will send them strong delusion that they
should believe the lie that they all may
be condemned who did not believe the
truth but had pleasure in
unrighteousness think about what kind of
a lie would Kanye West be
entertaining about
God I know the plans that I have for
youh right if you actually read the
Bible and you said they're not plans to
hurt me harm me destroy me they're
actually PL plans that I may prosper in
life and I'm going to put my faith and
trust that God no matter what you do or
what you say is going to somehow be good
for me down the road
that's having a belief in whatever
delusion that you do not believe the
truth you got to know what the Bible
says and you got to place your trust in
that so the
chosen we've talked about this show fact
this is something that no matter where I
go and speak this is a question that
comes up time and time again so in the
chosen Jesus has a conversation with
John the Baptist now John the Baptist is
somebody in the Bible that Jesus
referred to as there's no person on the
planet like this guy he's so principled
it's ridiculous so so I understand kind
of what the writers were writing in this
but instead of like making him this like
super principled person that was really
focused on on you know a call to
repentance and a call to re Revival and
and all of those things right they made
him sort of this leader of a sort of a
revolt and that he's going to yeah you
was kind of weird portrayal John and
Jesus were on the same page they had the
same goals essentially you know he was
the Forerunner he was going before to
prepare the way for Jesus submission you
have to be on the same page for that
yeah so so in this clip you're going to
see Jesus talking with his cousin John
and just listen to the sort of arrogance
that JN has like I'm going to do this
and my followers are going to love it
they're G to just like you know hate on
hate on Herod and this and that but
listen to Jesus's response when they
start talking about incest I left Jacob
and the rest of my followers in Jericho
to preach repentance I have to go back
to Jerusalem Jerusalem we were all just
theread you didn't hear the news what
Herod divorced facilis and is marrying
herodias his brother's ex-wife someone
has to call them out on this
filth good men will you allow me a
moment with my cousin it is right there
in the book of Moses if a man takes his
brother's wife it is impur he has
uncovered his brothers nakedness and
they shall be childless I understand
this against the law of Moses but I'm
here for bigger purposes than the
breaking of rules minimize incest of
course not wait a minute I'm here for
greater purposes than Breaking breaking
rules wait a minute and they're
discussing incest and John's just
confused with like I'm going to go tell
these these people off Herod and and
herodias and and what Jesus you you you
you condone um you know something that
that they held up the law of Moses as
like crowning thing and he's just like
oh no I'm I'm here for something bigger
than that you you know I got to say I've
seen this this is the last season I
watched before I watched our episode and
on the chosen I stopped watching The
Chosen this is new to me you know why
because it went right over my head but I
bet you it's somewhere you know like
what what yeah and isn't that just crazy
if you actually seriously consider
consider what's happening here because
Jesus is going like okay I'm here for
something else and and and you know
that's not that big of a deal or
whatever he's doing and it's like people
were put to death for those things in
the Old Testament yeah it it's almost
like they're playing the two
extremes you know like John is just
concerned about the letter of the law
and you know smack down give it to him
no love don't care just call him out you
know and Jesus is like no no no we don't
need to worry about the rules like
there's bigger things at play and it's
like neither one of those is actually
what Jesus was doing form of
godliness denying the power well also
and why did Jesus come down in the first
place we talked about it earlier because
the the the Ten Commandments were
transgressed sin is the transgression of
the law there would not we not be in sin
right now if there was no law there is a
law it's the Ten Commandments and he's
just being like and I know he's um he
might be referring to the law of Moses
in here which was ceremonial laws which
is what Paul referred to what that was
nailed to the cross not the Ten
Commandments that was fulfilled in Jesus
not the Ten Commandments The Ten
Commandments are still valid but either
way it's planting a seed in your mind
and it wouldn't surprise me I've not
seen the following Seasons I'm not here
to watch season 5 would not surprise me
if they're setting this up as like once
Jesus dies and resurrects it's like oh
the Law's been done away with there are
still some laws of Moses that apply
today usually should not be know having
beastiality okay yes of course of course
so that is not in the Ten Commandments
and we still as Christians we would
agree that that's not okay I understand
what you're saying about the laws that
were that were you know nailed to the
cross of course Sanctuary yeah Jesus
himself said I came to fulfill the law
not to break it exactly so for PE for
you know the the seed that is planted
here on people to watch I've never
watched like chosen ever the chosen but
the the seed that that is planted from a
single scene like that is like oh okay
well I can do the little sins here it's
no big deal like like you're were saying
right it's like Jesus didn't doesn't
really care it's as long as you love him
you know we're all saved through Grace
and stuff like that and you know it
makes Jesus sacrifice almost like kind
of last valuable and the problem is and
you've mentioned this many times before
that this is the picture of Jesus you
have in your mind when you think about
Jesus including when you're praying and
I actually recently had an experience
with this I was studying something with
my husband or we were at a Bible study
and um we were we're going through a
book about the life of Jesus and then
reading the scriptures with it it's like
a commentary anyway so the by the person
giving the Bible study was like so what
happened here with like Phillip and call
Nathaniel and Jesus and calling them all
and I literally I stopped and I couldn't
answer cuz in my mind I had the picture
of the Chosen and I was like I don't
know if this picture is correct and it
wasn't it actually I mean we know from
The Chosen he's not like the whole issue
with Nathaniel being an architect and
stuff it's not but still I was like did
J you know they were like in the alley
and then Jesus talked to them I was like
was that what happened or was it like
this and the anyway I I struggled I
couldn't answer and it so it it shows
you how it just sticks here and I think
that's why the we brought it out in the
documentary that we had about the chosen
if you have a question about that please
check out that video but Dan hasseltine
and Matthew Nelson listen to what they
say about every single episode is
pushing back on this idea that Jesus
isn't here for the rules and the laws
well why do you think the chosen it has
Universal appeal you talked about that I
mean it's not just Christian audiences
it's mainstream audiences people that
don't know Christ at all are loving this
show what is driving this yeah I I mean
I think I think it's hard to find
somebody who doesn't know Christ at all
um but I think they know a version of
religion or version of Faith um I think
the stories we tell about Jesus are not
very compelling um yeah and and so I
think when they see this version of
Jesus portrayed I think it really does
it it matters that he's
merciful that he's
he's extending a lot of Grace um he has
his own flaws in a human way like he's
very relatable and um and gracious and I
think people need to see that that side
of Jesus cuz we've a lot of us have been
force-fed um you know a a version of
Jesus that only cares about our
behaviors um and every episode the story
pushes is back on that you know every
episode it tries to turn the table on oh
your behavior is not actually what
matters it is it is the inner workings
of your heart and your soul that will
matter um and he keeps kind of pushing
that you know there's no shame there's
no condemnation there's those kinds of
ideas that we we've gotten out of the
habit of talking about in the church at
large I think it's if if people have an
experience in the church most often it's
something that is focused on their
behavior Bible says as a man
thinks in his heart so is he yeah this
to come
out in your behavior yes and Jesus is
trying to
change this he's trying to change our
mind trying to change our thoughts our
minds in and and along with that our
Behavior will change so that every
thought will be brought into the
Captivity of Christ MH it's like when
you read the Bible and you take a step
back and you go what is God really
wanting he's wanting us to make a change
I think if you were to sit down with any
Christian and ask this simple question
does God want you to continue in sin no
I mean it seems like it would be a
pretty simple answer and yet we continue
to buy into this narrative that Jesus
doesn't care about our he Behavior you
know and and that we can just make Jesus
like us we can do whatever we want you
know and keep doing whatever we want and
it doesn't
matter but I think that a lot of
Christians think well I'm pretty good
and so as long as I'm not you know uh
committing adultery or stealing or or
killing anybody I'm living a pretty good
life I'm in church every single week
then yeah I that's fine that's all he
wants and and that's what I was
mentioning earlier just that the idea of
call in the name of Jesus and you'll be
saved is so much bigger than that cuz
you have to read the context of the
whole Bible
that's the leoan message though because
the leoan church think about it it's a
church mhh it's a church and it
represents God's Church in the last days
and what do you see in Christianity in
the last days I'm rich I'm increased
with Goods I don't need anything
including Jesus I don't need to change I
don't need to change what you're
watching is a is a Jesus that is being
sold to the world that really has no you
know sort of power of changing your life
Matthew 7 you guys brought this up and
um denique read this just just for the
sake since you read it it's not everyone
who says to me Lord Lord shall enter
into the kingdom of heaven but he who
does the will of my Father in Heaven
pause for a second but he who does the
will of the father what is the will if
you love me keep my Commandments yes but
you can distill it down into two
thoughts all the law and the prophets
hang on these two thoughts yep love God
mhm love your neighbor mhm so if you can
hang everything on to those pieces and
that's why we see these commercials that
are in the in the um beginning here at
the at the Super Bowl right you've got
people helping people people doing all
these seemingly good pieces of work okay
they're doing all these things for God
and you're noticing you know they're
holding the LGBT flag up in the
background and all this they're doing
all these wonderful things right they're
not thinking of this as a whole biblical
concept now go ahead and finish reading
this many will say to me in that day
Lord Lord have we not prophesied in your
name cast out demons in your name and
done many wonders in your name and then
I will declare to them I never knew you
depart from me you who practice
lawlessness some pretty scary words if
the Bible tells you in the law of Moses
that there are certain activities that
you should not do because it is a form
of adultery you shouldn't do it mhm and
that doesn't mean that this is cart
blanch you checked the box and yes we're
all Sinners and so now you can continue
in sin God forbid that right and so we
keep thinking that you know what
religion is a great thing it's really a
good thing in people's lives I want
everybody to have an experience with God
I agree amen we are actually seeing our
government start to say let's put God
back into the picture let's put him into
the schools let's put him in back into
law that's what we saw right who's the
lady that's sitting just to the right of
trump Paula White yeah she's a spiritual
adviser T evangelist the spiritual
advisor this is coming from the White
House right here what's the date at the
bottom here February 7 2025 so they just
appointed her as the spiritual advisor
Paula White she can um basically is
going to be the one that is in charge of
the faith branch of the government and
who is she married to that's interesting
who she married Jonathan Kane of Journey
okay so Jonathan Kane of Journey we're
gonna get to that in just a second Paula
has really kind of gotten a bad rap I
think because she's a public television
evangelist um and you know she really
got her legs underneath her by preaching
the Prosperity Gospel what's the
Prosperity
Gospel send your money to the tele
evangelist and Jesus will bless you okay
so more money you get to the point to
the point I'll play a clip of you this
to the point of if you send a certain
amount of money you are storing this
away in heaven look at this right now
someone is about to send you that
million dooll check in the name of Jesus
you just seemly need to be obedient
whether it's $100,000 whether it's
$10,000 it's going to be wonderful that
you have your plaque this is beautiful
as blown away because I was like he's
going to think I stole some my stuff
from him cuz God's been downloading
several things that are so similar
seriously and and you have got to right
now become one of those pillars become
one of those people whether it's the
10,000 or the thousand and with all due
respect as great as that name is going
to be left there there's a greater name
that's going to be written every
treasure you give here on Earth is being
stored Up In Heaven There is a
Department of Treasury in heaven now I
know minutian is over down here but I'm
telling you there's a Department of
Treasury in heaven that God is watching
over everything you do and you are
storing up Eternal treasure that will go
so far beyond I think that we can even
begin to imagine that you are mandated
by God I feel a mandated I know I was
supposed to come share my book but I
feel a mandate to help you build this
have you ever seen that video where
she's like she she she doesn't appeal
for for money as well and she's like
yeah you going to give $10,000 no you're
going to give $100,000 $500,000 because
and if you don't do this then it's like
people are put down like if you don't do
this your relationship with God is
ruined so you better give your money yes
and and you know we make appeals in
churches to give to the offering plate
and but the purpose to give to God is
not so that you have some sort of return
on that God is Not A Bank in heaven that
if I give you a th000 bucks you're going
to give me a million bucks back because
who wouldn't send you a th000 bucks I
mean she's even said have you ever have
you ever seen the clips where she'll say
like um I don't know what they are but
like like Mark 232 if you send
$232 this verse will become a reality in
your life I was like no it's like
Christian numerology yeah it's like what
is the 232 actuating that verse to
become like turned on and off the danger
is though that she does call herself a
profit she's also intoed a new stolic
Reformation which is and a seven Mount
mandate which is all about basically
forcing the second coming of Jesus by
push putting the you know Christianity
vales over every aspect every aspect of
life including politics which is all
fulfillment of Prophecy we have a video
on that too but yeah this is really
dangerous that people see her like this
they look up to her and they feel like
you're a prophet I you're the voice of
God like indulgences though almost yeah
almost tinkering on that right well she
actually has said that she went to
heaven did you know that no she saw God
okay interesting my spirit went up and I
literally went to the throne room of
God I won't say much but I'll say
something that's important for me to
teach you here
today so in that Divine encounter I
don't know how long I was there I just
no that kind of power is almost
impossible for a natural body to
contain and as I went to the throne room
of God first I saw there was a Mist that
was coming off the water and I went to
the throne of God and I didn't see God's
face clearly but I saw the face of God
wasn't it clear not like I could see
your face clearly but I knew it was the
face of God and as God begin
he put a mantle on me and it was a very
distinct mantle I had no idea that
Apostle had prophesied I think you said
that there was a mantle that was coming
upon me that there was a new mantle
coming upon
me and there was a mantle and I saw it
very distinctly the color was like a a
goldish but it did it was a yellowish
goldish a little bit different than your
scarf a little bit brighter than your
scarf there
and then I saw the Earth for a moment
and then he brought me back and he put
me in certain places one being the White
House one building certain continents it
was a mass
move I didn't come out of that really
until the next morning so she goes and
she sees God God puts a mantle on her
what do you think about that and tells
her where she's going to
be I look at these things in two ways
you're either telling the truth or
you're lying mhm and if you're telling
the truth then what you have to believe
is that this person was put there by God
and told they were going to be at the
White House if you don't believe what
she says then you don't believe that God
put her in that position mhm I I
personally don't believe it yeah of
course but look at what that does
psychologically to your audience mhm
well yeah and there's a lot of this that
happens in politics on on both sides
when your candidate wins you know then
it's God sets up Kings but as soon as
your candidate doesn't win then it's
like God removes Kings you know and it's
like we kind of apply it based on our
our personal preference or
perspective it's so true I also want to
add Jesus wouldn't go around flaunting
like you know look at me God put me in
the White House God put me here like you
just could have gone around and
constantly just paraded around like that
and and he would have the right because
he's Jesus but he didn't he was humble
and meek and that's kind of the opposite
I don't I don't know if Elisha wore the
mantle around and told people like you
know this mantle came from you know what
I
mean I would agree with you so uh this
is this is her husband the one that was
the journey guy okay have you seen this
clip no okay so they're talking they're
in a church set setting they're at a
marriage conference and they're giving
marital advice to people but she sorry
she was divorced a few times before that
she was here's probably
why another part of it is ladies if you
don't know what he likes you know figure
it out get a book what go get some porn
do something whatever if he likes to
watch porn watch porn with him you know
what I mean it's it's
like you got to get where you going to
go
figure it
out son fell on the
floor did he say that at church did he
say watch porn marriage Retreat yes I
think that's what he said I was double
checking to make sure I heard it right
you yes you heard that right I mean I'm
not saying that she watches that but
it's like why would you say that like
weird
2015 that's not very long AG
and granted to her um defense if you
would she quickly bounced back and was
like okay I know how people are going to
take this we don't watch porn I don't
think I don't think he said that with
like you know you shouldn't do this she
recognized people are going to have a
field day with this she corrected it
when she was here but it just kind of
goes to show you like probably where his
head space is at in fact when he met her
he was still married and yeah you guys
can take that for whatever it yeah she
also went with Benny Hinn at one point
while being one of them was married yeah
wow so the Bible says in John 1:7 but if
we walk in the light as he is in the
light we have fellowship with one
another the blood of Jesus his son
cleanses us from all sin amen this is
what I truly believe that the Bible and
Christianity should do in your life it
will cause you to have good
relationships with one another and we've
talked about this on this channel if
you're watching porn with your spouse
that's not a really good way to build a
relationship in your marriage yeah
you're treating on each other together
so once again if you walk in the light
the Bible has a lot to say about these
types of things and you have fellowship
with one another meaning your
relationships are going to be blessed
and and you're going to work that out
and you're letting Jesus his son be the
king in your heart it will change your
life amen the Bible I believe is a
wonderful tool and you know but people
can read it and not be changed mhm I
mean that doesn't give you a guarantee
just because you read that you need to
let Jesus into your heart to believe
that that that God is the king and he
will have an impact in your life and I I
I I felt like bringing this up seriously
because I believe that we are being sold
right now a version of Jesus in our
world
that religion is about ticking that box
has nothing to do on me I don't have to
really change which you brought up the
Le oysan message and so brothers and
sisters we're here we've been told this
in the Bible many times we know that
this is coming down the pipe for those
of you that that maybe are further down
the road and you're understanding and
you know what I'm talking about we're
here like we're at this moment that you
are beginning to start to see these
things happen so as you guys can see
there is a lot of good things about
religion coming into our public space
but we know prophesied from the Bible
from a long time ago that these things
will become increasingly stronger and
stronger at the end of time and we know
that there is going to be a counterfeit
of the real gospel
so what you need to do is you need to
start studying your Bible Bible School
Bible School L.T v/b School ask for the
holy spirit's understanding and know and
pay attention to what day and age we are
it is High Time choose God today amen if
you like this video like comment
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you know when we launch new videos
and drop a comments below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say m